what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
today we have something that I think not
only Marvel fans but just movie fans in
general are going to find extremely
interesting Chris Hemsworth has recently
done a really big interview with GQ
Magazine I loved reading the article and
I definitely suggest everybody go check
out the full thing on gq's website
because they really dive into the life
and the career of Chris Hemsworth it was
truly a great read but today of course
we're going to be talking about what he
has recently said about Marvel Studios
he's talked about his time as Thor he
also talks about the criticism that Thor
11 Thunder got and he also offers a bit
of constructive criticism for Marvel
moving forward as well talking about how
to avoid that Marvel fatigue and how to
avoid all of these movies and projects
kind of being the same thing and I gotta
say I agree with what he is saying in
this interview I think it's very
insightful and I hope this is the way
that Marvel Studio is actually continues
to push forward now and in the future
and he also talks about the criticism
that Martin Scorsese had for the MCU so
some deep stuff we're diving into today
and if you love Marvel be sure to
subscribe to the channel and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
also entered in our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so the first thing they really
dive into with Marvel in this very long
but awesome GQ article is actually that
criticism by Martin Scorsese and what
Chris Hemsworth thought of it the
article States still he bristles when I
ask him about criticisms of Marvel by
filmmakers such as Martin Scorsese and
Quentin Tarantino who recently queried
whether Marvel actors are really movie
stars in a podcast interview last year
Quentin Tarantino said that the
characters not the actors are the stars
and Chris Hemsworth said to this that's
super depressing when I hear that there
goes two of my heroes I won't work with
I guess they're not a fan of me I'm
thankful that I have been a part of
something that kept people in cinemas
now whether or not those films were to
the detriment of other films I don't
know I don't love when we start
scrutinizing each other when there's so
much fragility in the business and in
the space of the Arts as it is I say
that less to the directors who made
those comments who are all by the way
still my heroes and in a heartbeat I
would leap to work with any of them but
I say it more to the broader opinion
around that topic I don't think any of
us have the answer but we're trying this
was a very classy way to respond to this
criticism and if you have an opinion on
this let us know Down Below in the
comments do you think the characters or
the actors are the actual Stars I think
both because just imagine Robert Downey
Jr not playing Iron Man imagine Iron Man
played by somebody else Robert Downey Jr
did make the character but the character
is also amazing the same thing goes with
Chris Hemsworth and Thor and Chris Evans
and Captain America yes the characters
are amazing but the actors do such an
incredible job and fit the part so well
that they make the characters what they
are so I definitely think that the
actors are the stars because they make
the characters and the characters are of
course the stars as well but now we jump
into a little bit more of the criticism
that he got for Thor love and thunder
criticism about Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and what he thinks Thor 5
should be like the article continues to
State Everyone's a Critic these days
even Hemsworth's kids friends were in on
it with his most recent Marvel offering
Thor love and thunder they didn't hold
back Chris Hemsworth said it's a bunch
of eight-year-olds critiquing my film we
thought this one had too much humor the
action was cool but the VFX weren't as
good he recalls I cringe and laugh
equally at it and even Chris Hemsworth
looking back says that he realizes where
there were some problems and he offers
his own critique he States I think we
just had too much fun it just became too
silly it's always hard being in the
cinder of it and how having any real
perspective I love the process it's
always a ride but you just don't know
how people are going to respond and I
definitely agree that it was pretty
silly I actually kind of liked the humor
but as Chris Hemsworth is about to say
in this interview he does think that
four five definitely needs to be
different than I do as well when asked
about doing more Thor movies he stated I
love the experience I love the fact that
I've been able to do something fairly
different throughout the process Thor
one and two were their own thing or
three and four were a very different
feel and then even Avengers the Lebowski
Thor the infinity War Thor due to
different directors and I think mostly
my own need to do something different
you know I got sick of the character
pretty quick every couple of years if I
was going to do something again it would
have to be tonally different and we'd
have to do something very drastic to
keep people on their toes otherwise it's
just the fatigue of those characters and
those films where people are like I've
seen it and I think that MO most people
would agree here I think Thor Ragnarok
was so good because it was so fresh it
was a different take on Thor and sure
Thor love and thunder might have been
over the top it might have had too many
jokes but it was pretty much the same
Thor from Ragnarok whereas Thor 1 and
Thor 2 were the same Thor as well so now
going into Thor 5 I think we would need
both that serious Thor and comedic Thor
kind of meshed together a combination of
the first two Thor films and the second
two and here's where Chris Hemsworth
offers kind of some general Marvel
criticism that I think he's very right
about I think this really makes sense
and they go on to talk about Black
Panther wakanda forever talking about
how he saw it and he thought that it was
really cool but he hasn't seen Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania yet but he
asked the interviewer Hannah Rose Lee
what she thought of the movie in which
she said her opinion which essentially
was why did they have to make it so big
talking about Ant-Man quantumania in
which Chris Hemsworth said that's the
trick you have to separate all those
Stories the moment it's like and then he
pretended to do a trailer narrator voice
stating your world is in danger the
entire universe and Chris Hemsworth goes
it's like yeah so it was the last 24
films it has to become a bit more
personal and grounded and that is kind
of true a lot of the films have had that
same premise the world's in danger the
universe is in danger and if you do too
many like that they do start to lose
their personal touch now don't get me
wrong I like the fact that everything is
connected and of course the entire world
and Multiverse is going to be in danger
due to King but I think there does need
to be a bit more of a personal touch per
project to make things really seem like
they're their own thing that was so
great about phase one phase two and
phase three of the MCU we got our
individual projects that were their own
thing Iron Man films were Iron Man films
yes they connected to the overall story
arc of the Avengers but they came
together for that Arc specifically in
The Avengers films and the Iron Man
films the Indian of the universe wasn't
really the problem they had the
individual villains to deal with same
thing with the Captain America movies
even Civil War wasn't about the universe
or the world being threatened it was a
fight between our heroes and kind of
Baron zema yes they connected to the
overall story of the MCU which was yeah
hey the world and the universe is in
danger but they still had that Personal
Touch which I do believe was a very
great thing and should continue on in
the MCU but let us know your thoughts
about that what do you think in the
comments down below now as far as thwart
5 is concerned his final words on that
are that he is open to it the article
continues and says he is always open to
returning a store seeing what they have
to offer creatively if there is
something new for the character but then
he says and I quote but I really want to
do some other stuff for a while end
quote so he's open to Thor but he wants
to do some other stuff first this means
he probably has a few years until he
makes his return in secret Wars or
perhaps the King Dynasty we'll have to
see which one of course he can't really
talk about that he can't give anything
away so it's not like he can say
actually I am returning as Thor pretty
soon you'll see me in the next Avengers
movie he can't really say that and he
was most likely specifically talking
about a solo Thor film Thor five when he
said that he probably wasn't talking
about the next Avengers team-up films
those of course are a little bit
different but let me know what you think
about what he said in this article do
you agree with his criticism and what do
you think Thor 5 should be like also do
be sure to check out the full article
it's a really great Insight on the life
of Chris Hemsworth and just a good read
don't forget to like the video and of
course subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and don't forget to
check out our patreon our website and
our Discord server as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf
beep